El parlamento Turco ha aprobado hoy una
nueva ley contra la desinformación que
según los críticos de este nuevo texto
será una ley de censura Según esto el de
texto de esta nueva ley el gobierno y el
sistema judicial Turco podrá condenar
apenas de hasta tres años de cárcel a
cualquiera que Esparza o publique
información que sea dirimida como falsa
podrán ser tantos ciudadanos como
también periodistas quién decidirá qué
es qué noticia Cuál es verdadera será el
propio gobierno de reset type erdogan
que explica según este texto que también
podrán ser investigadas y condenadas
personas que retuiteen en esta supuesta
información falsa partidos opositores
han asegurado que después de votar en
contra de esta ley que ha sido probada
igualmente apelarán al tribunal
constitucional para que intente revocar
esta ley que aún no ha sido firmada por
el gobierno de presidente Turco recepta
y perdón en cuanto lo sea han dicho los
opositores intentarán apelar contra esta
nueva ley que los defensores de los
Derechos Humanos
libertad de expresión aseguran que viene
justo antes de momento crucial para
Turquía aseguran estas organizaciones
que el gobierno quiere silenciar las
voces críticas que se levantan ahora
mismo en contra de erdogan en un momento
en que llegan elecciones presidenciales
en primavera de este año según la gran
mayoría de las encuestas el presidente
Turco perdería esos comicios ante una
posición cada vez más fuerte y según
estas organizaciones el gobierno querría
callar estas voces tanto de periodistas
como de ciudadanos ante un momento clave
para Turquía